très belle et louise fenech sortant de
l'eau et aldo maccione y rentrant vous
les aimez comment les femmes d'habitude
comme ça alors comme ça si vous auriez
amabilités genre historique et de nous
donner des nouvelles de la météo mon
cher aldo et pourquoi
mais bon et hino méthodologique aux
maîtresses et humble et christophe pomez
ridge racer toute la france un possible
participation était presque sur le canal
pdc considère à des magyars spaghettis
il tempo d'aumagne d'aller aperçu de la
corsica thèmes propres à bien de
nouveaux locaux en date est un port à
l'esc une tempête du riz va se battre a
ajouté de la france avec le film tu es
toi qu'as tu parles
et s'ils considèrent s'impose pas guette
voilà j'ai connu des gens nous allons
tenir compte de vos prévisions météo
mais je vous signale que le journal
n'est quand même pas terminé oui vous
avez raison
ah oui la bourse et françois donati
bellissimo françois donne à pile à la
classe france soit donati c'est le
soleil il a la balle sort
et mme hall cobain et la bourse de paris
aujourd'hui accentue encore la tendance
à l'amélioration qui était la sienne
depuis deux jours